[Music]
as a nuclear inspector we are entitled
to go in the name of the European Union
or in the name of the community and also
under the eurom treaty to any of the
Civil nuclear installations within the
European Union and we are entitled to
verify the Declarations and to verify
the the material and the accountancy and
also the physical state of the material
and to check whether the Declarations
and the the use are of the material are
according to the
Declaration it's a great place to work
not only to work itself because we can
access uh installations and sites that
are not generally open to the public we
work in a highly technical environment
that offers great opportunities to
develop we travel across Europe or
across the union um and um Luxembourg is
a very nice place to live and to
work
[Music]